uh
you
oh
she didn't see us on it i said that's
because
uh
okay
okay
you
foreign
uh
okay
over there over there
mic check one two one two mic check one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
happy thanksgiving one two three four
five
six seven eight nine ten ten nine eight
seven six five four three
two one hey hey one two
mic check one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten ten
nine eight seven six five four
three two one mike check hey hey one
two three four five six seven
eight nine ten ten nine eight
copy that
sometimes
okay
uh
mike check one two three four mic check
one two
three four five six all good
oh good thumbs up thank you
perfect
um
innovations
making sure
this is
actually
more
sir
i'm
different colors
oh
uh
movies
good morning
you accepted
okay
huh
yes
you
so
my fellow americans thanksgiving is a
special time in america
a time to reflect on what the year has
brought
to think about what lies ahead
you know our first national day of
thanksgiving
authorized by the continental congress
took place on december 18
1777.
was celebrated by general george
washington and his troops at gulf mills
on the way to valley forge it took place
under extremely harsh conditions and
deprivation
lacking food clothing shelter
they're preparing to ride out a long
hard winter
today you can find a plaque in gulf
mills marking that moment
here's the plaque reads it says this
thanksgiving
in spite of the suffering showed the
reverence and character
that was forging the soul of a nation
forging the soul of a nation
faith courage sacrifice
service to country service to each other
and gratitude even in the face of
suffering
have long been part of what thanksgiving
means in america
you know looking back over our history
you see that it's been in the most
difficult circumstances that the soul of
our nation
has been forged and now we find
ourselves
again facing a long hard winter
we fought a nearly year-long battle with
a virus
that has devastated this nation this
brought us pain and loss and frustration
and has cost so many lives
260 000 americans in county
this divided us angered us
set us against one another i know the
country has grown
weary of the fight we need to remember
we're at war with the virus not with one
another
not with each other this is the moment
where we need to steal our spines
redouble our efforts and recommit
ourselves to the fight
let's remember we're all in this
together
sounds trite to say but we're all in
this together
for so many of us it's hard to hear this
fight isn't over
we still have months of this battle
ahead of us
for those who've lost a loved one
i know that this time of year can be
especially difficult
believe me i know
i remember that first thanksgiving the
empty chair
the silence takes your breath away
it's really hard to care it's hard to
give thanks
it's hard to even think of looking
forward
it's so hard to hope
i understand i i'll be thinking and
praying for each and every one of you
this thanksgiving at your thanksgiving
table because
we've been there this year we're asking
americans to forgo so
many of the traditions that we've long
made
this holiday which made it so special
for our families for 40 such years
40-some years we've had a tradition of
traveling over thanksgiving
tradition we've kept every year save one
the year our son bo died
but this year we'll be staying at home
we've always had a big family gatherings
of thanksgiving
kids grandkids aunts uncles brothers
sisters
and more but the bidens the days around
thanksgiving have
always been a time to remember all we
had to be grateful for
and a time to begin to think about
christmas and again even to do the
christmas lists
but this year because we care so much
for each other
we're going to be having a separate
thanksgiving
for jill and i we'll be at our home in
delaware with our daughter
and our son-in-law the rest of the
family will be
doing the same thing in small groups so
i know
i know how hard it is to forego family
traditions
but it's so very important our country's
in the middle of a dramatic spike in
cases
we're now averaging 160 thousand
new cases a day no one will be surprised
if we hit
200 000 cases in a single day
many local health system is at risk of
being overwhelmed
that's the plain and simple truth
nothing made up it's real
and i believe you always deserve to hear
the truth
hear the truth from your president
we have to try to slow the growth of
this virus
we owe it to the doctors and the nurses
and other front-line workers
care workers who've risked their lives
some lost their life put so much on the
line
in a heroic battle in this virus
against it for so long
you know we owe that to our fellow
citizens who need access to hospital
beds
and care to fight this disease we owe it
to one another
it's literally our patriotic duty as
americans
it means wearing a mask keeping social
distancing
limiting the size of any group we're in
until we have a vaccine these are the
most effective tools to combat the virus
starting on day one of my presidency
we will take steps that will change the
course of this disease
more testing will find people with cases
and get them away from one another
slowing the number of infections more
protective gear for businesses in our
schools
to do the same reducing the number of
cases
clear guidance will get more businesses
and more schools open
we all have a role to play in beating
this crisis
the federal government has vast powers
to combat the virus and i commit to you
i will use
all of those powers to lead a national
coordinated response
but but the federal government can't do
this alone
each of us has a responsibility in our
own lives
do what we can do to slow the virus
every decision we make matters every
decision we make can save lives
none of these steps we're asking people
to take are political statements
every one of them is based on science
real science
now the good news is there has been
significant record-breaking progress
made recently in developing a vaccine
and several of these vaccines look
extraordinarily effective
and it happens that we're on track for
the first immunization to begin
by late december early january
then we'll need to put in place a
distribution plan
to get the entire country immunized as
soon as possible
which we will do but it's going to take
time
i'm hoping the news of the vaccine will
serve as an
incentive to every american to take
these
simple steps to get control of the virus
there's real hope tangible hope
so hang on don't let yourself surrender
to the fatigue which i understand
it is real fatigue i know we can
and we will beat this virus
america's not going to lose this war
we'll get our lives back
life is going to return to normal i
promise you this
will happen this will not last forever
so yes it's been a really hard year
particularly hard for over 250
000 people in their families but i still
believe we have much to be thankful for
there's so much to hope for much to
build on
much to dream of
here's the america i see and i believe
it's the america you see as well
america that faces facts
an america that overcomes challenges an
america that we
where we seek justice and equality for
all people
and america holds fast to the conviction
that out of pain comes
possibility out of frustration comes
progress and out of division
unity you all know in our finest hours
that's who we've always been and that's
how we shall be again
for i believe that this grim season of
division
demonization is going to give way to a
year of light and immunity
why do i think so because america is a
nation
not of adversaries but of neighbors
not of limitations but of possibilities
not of dreams deferred but of dreams
realized
i've said many times that this is a
great country
we are a good people this is the united
states of america
and there's never been anything we've
been unable to do
when we've done it together think of
what we come through
as a nation how many things we've come
through centuries of human enslavement
cataclysmic civil war exclusion of women
from the battle box
world wars jim crow
the long twilight struggle against
soviet tyranny that
ended not in the fall berlin wall but
nuclear armageddon
look i'm not naive i know that history
is just that
history but to know what came before
would come
before what's happened before help
armist against despair
knowing that previous generations got
through the same universal human
challenge that we face
the tension between selfishness and
generosity
between fear and hope between division
and unity
and what what was it that brought the
reality
of america into closer alignment with
the promise of reality justice and
prosperity
sounds corny but it was love plain and
simple
love of country love of one another
we don't talk much about love in our
politics
the political the political ring is too
loud
too angry too heated to love our
neighbor
as ourselves is a radical act
it is what we're called to do
we must try for
only in trying only in listening
only in seeing ourselves as bound
together and what dr king called
the mutual garment of destiny can we
rise above
the visions and truly heal
look we all know america's never been
perfect
but we've always tried to fulfill the
aspiration
of the declaration of independence that
all
people are created equal created in the
image of god
and we've always sought to form a more
perfect union
what should we give thanks for this
season well
first let's be thankful for democracy
itself
and listen in this last election the one
that just took place
we've seen record numbers of americans
exercise the most sacred right that of
the vote
to register their will at the ballot box
think about that
in the middle of a pandemic more people
voted this year than have ever voted in
the history
of the united states of america over
150 million people
cast a ballot simply extraordinary
many waiting in line five six seven
eight hours to vote
if you want to know what beats deep in
the heart of america it's this democracy
the right to determine our lives our
government and our leaders
the right to be heard our democracy has
tested this year
and what we learned is this the people
of this nation are
up to the task in america we have full
and fair and free elections
and then we honor the results the people
of this nation
and the laws of the land won't stand for
anything else
through the vote the noblest instrument
of non-violent protests ever conceived
we remained anew
and we're reminded anew that progress is
possible
that we the people we the people
have the power to change what jefferson
called the course of human events
and with our hearts and our hands and
our voices
today we can be better than yesterday
and tomorrow we can be still better than
that day you know we should be thankful
too
that america is a covenant an unfolding
story
we have what we need to create
prosperity opportunity and justice
americans have grit and generosity a
capacity for
greatness and reservoirs of goodness
we have what it takes now we have to act
this is our moment ours together
to write a newer bolder more
compassionate chapter
in the life of the nation the work ahead
is not going to be easy
it will not be quick you want solutions
not shouting
reason not hyperpartisanship light not
heat
you want us to hear one another again
see
one another again respect one another
again
you want democrats and republicans and
independents to come together and work
together
and that my friends is what i'm
determined
to do americans dream big
as hard as it may seem this thanksgiving
we're going to dream big again
our future is bright the fact we've
never been
i've never been more optimistic about
the future america than i am right now
i honest to god believe the 21st century
is going to be an american century
we're going to build an economy that
leads the world
we're going to lead the world by the
power of our example not just the
example of our power
we're going to lead the world on climate
and save this planet
we're going to find cures for cancer and
alzheimer's and diabetes
i promise you we're going gonna finally
root out systemic racism in this country
on this thanksgiving in anticipation of
all the thanksgivings that come
let's dream again let's commit
let's commit ourselves to thinking not
only of ourselves
but of others as well for if we care for
one another
if we open our arms rather than
brandishing our fists
we can with the help of god heal
and if we do and i'm sure we can
we can proclaim the promised
with the promise who wrote these
following words
the lord is my strength and my shield
and with my song i give thanks to him
i give thanks now for you
for the trust you placed in me
together we'll lift our voices in the
coming months and years and our songs
shall be
of lives saved breaches repaired
a nation made whole again
folks from abiding family to yours
wherever and however you may be
celebrated
we wish you a happy thanksgiving
may god bless you may god protect our
troops
happy thanksgiving
up